how you doing people welcome to the
Rubin report I'm Dave Rubin and we have
a smart and heady show for you as
opposed to the not smart not heady shows
that we've been pumping out for the last
year
Jacqueline Glenn Cara Santa Maria these
are too smart sciency chicks can I say
that are you both comfortable with that
description science science at chicks
fair enough we're okay with that chick
is is that available all right I feel
good about this we got a bunch of topics
that I think that they're really going
to want to sink their teeth into so here
we go a school in Fort Lauderdale
Florida is in a bunch of hot water after
a teacher reportedly banned one of her
students from reading the Bible during
free reading time she actually called
the parents phone at home and left a
message and we've got some audio Thomas
Giovanna cold because I noticed that she
has a books a religious book get in the
classroom he's not permitted to read
those books in my classroom he said if I
told him to put it away you said you
said not to do that so please give me a
call I need a thorough understanding on
direction to him about the book he's
reading as opposed to the curriculum for
public school mrs. F promise thank you
and have a wonderful day okay so this
brings up a lot of interesting things
obviously about freedom of religion and
this was free reading time at the school
which implies that the kids can read
anything that they want to read now I
know you guys aren't huge on religion so
I thought this would be an interesting
topic for you guys to handle what what
do you make of them of this teacher it
wasn't a school-wide thing apparently
but this teacher felt that this kid
could not read the Bible in class is
that okay no I don't think that's okay I
mean I'm normally very against having
religion in schools but that's having
the school push religion on the kids in
this case the kid just was an individual
who wanted to bring the book to school
and read it
and that's a personal choice and I don't
think that that should be handled the
way that they did you know Kyra personal
choice well I mean yeah the First
Amendment protects my right to not read
the Bible the same way it protects this
child's right to read the Bible this is
a blatant violation of the Constitution
and there's a you know there's action
being taken now there are lawyers that
are working with the with the students
family and this could potentially be
pushed up through the court system so I
I'm not sure if this teacher is aware of
the fact that she's violating the
Constitution by telling this child that
he can't read this book in her classroom
and maybe that'll be corrected as soon
as she kind of reads the Constitution
yeah
like that kid reading the Bible is going
to influence the other kids around them
you know it's not being forced on
anybody even if it get influenced the
other kids around him it doesn't matter
because the truth is that is a ace that
our like the law of the land protects so
this wasn't something that was like you
said part of the curriculum this isn't
something the teacher was pushing on to
the students but yes you have every
right to read whatever religious text
you want to read in a public place in a
private place whatever it'd be one thing
if he was reading this book when he was
supposed to be reading Tom Sawyer and
making a big stink about it but in free
reading class to tell a student that he
has to take his Bible out of the
classroom his Quran out of the classroom
his Torah out of the classroom whatever
is yeah it's a violation of the First
Amendment yeah I feel like carrying
around a Koran or at Oriel isn't that I
feel like it's a bigger book it's
something like I feel like that's a huge
thing I didn't used to seeing it kind of
in these in these words there are giant
Bibles - I'm pretty sure they're like an
ark and you have that like five people
pushing it your Bibles stopped here his
Bibles are myself yeah oh there's the
app like a million of those like stupid
Bible at all right you're right it's not
about the sizing but um should we be a
little afraid of so we're blaming this
on the teacher not the the school itself
so that that's one thing but should we
be a little afraid of these people that
are pushing the anti religion thing even
if you're not for religion in the public
sphere that they're pushing it to this
extent like that she called and she said
you know this isn't going to happen in
my class that there's there's a danger
real
in her methodology of how she's trying
to preach liberalism or so absolutely I
mean there's as much of a danger there
as there is pushing religion on kids you
don't want to make up their mind for
them it should be up to the child as we
were saying before yeah so yeah I mean I
don't know if a child can really make
those kinds of decisions I mean that's
another that's another debate entirely
but aside from that I I think we need
more context like is she preaching anti
religion or she so afraid of First
Amendment violations and afraid of all
the things that she's seen in the news
lately that she thought that this was
the right course of action like oh no I
don't want a Bible in my classroom
because I could get in trouble for that
maybe like that's the thing is that when
you become very extreme on one side or
the other of the issue I think and
because it's such a polarized issue it's
such a political kind of hot-button
issue I think that there's confusion
surrounding it and this again we don't
we don't have context it could be that
this woman was trying to push a specific
agenda it could be that she was afraid
of the opposite agenda being you know
seeming like it's being pushed in her
classroom so I think with a little more
context we would understand this a
little better but until then it's kind
of hard to tell yeah
where do you guys fall in terms of where
where the debate should be on this
because there is it seems to me you
could teach in a history class you could
teach about the historical existence of
Jesus and what was going on in that time
without giving a religious context to it
but should but you once you start doing
that then you open up a can of worms
where everyone wants to bring all the
the miracles and all that stuff in it so
where do you fall in terms of what we
can teach without teaching a myth
obviously there's no viable evidence
that Jesus actually Reilly wrote a book
about the historical yeah I go yeah
please take it away
they're stories there's you know
corroborating like tales and myths and
and and maybe non myths we don't know
but there's no there's no actual
evidence that there was a historical
figure named Jesus the way that there's
evidence of historical figures who you
know wrote things or where we have you
know their bones some plate like that
doesn't exist for it for Jesus Christ so
so and I'm not saying I don't think
Jesus Christ existed I have no [ __ ]
idea
but
don't think that in one empirical
everyone a pericle evidence and there's
absolutely nothing wrong with talking
about the history of religion or the
history of philosophy in those types of
courses I don't know if like Jesus's
existence should be taught in a history
class because I don't think we should be
making I mean so is that is that the
distinction that should be taught if
you're going to teach you in high school
for example it shouldn't be taught in
social studies but it could be taught in
in a philosophy yeah there's philosophy
there's electives you can choose to take
religion you can have Bible study
classes outside of the high school I
mean you can't just sit there and say
that I know Jesus was historical so I'm
going to teach it but you can't teach
the effects that religion had on history
I mean it's important and you can't
really avoid it yeah I mean that's going
to be part of your history class
regardless if you're learning about kind
of American history or if you're
learning about world history like you
can't avoid a conversation about
religion but I think religion as an
institution and it's sociological
effects it's a very different
conversation than the lore and the dogma
within a religion being taught as fact
like that that's where I start so the
church actually existing and and having
political you know machinations and
things like that that's real the walk on
water stuff yeah well we're all agree
it's that part in my history no
definitely nowhere near science all
right there you go I think we sum that
one up pretty well let's move on I
thought this was kind of fascinating a
25 year old woman named Emily let's
who's an abortion counselor from New
Jersey she filmed herself having an
abortion and this thing has been blowing
up and you might have seen it already
we're gonna show you just a little bit
of it I just want to share my story
to show women that there is such thing
as a positive abortion story pile at him
yeah that's exactly what a whole basket
bonfire like a girl
everyone deserve them okay so obviously
she was trying to show a positive
abortion story and she's obviously
pro-abortion she's an abortion counselor
I believe a woman has a right to choose
and I have no right to tell a woman what
to do with her own body but after
watching this I was really kind of
conflicted if this sort of helps the
cause of abortion or not because by
showing something that clinical it
actually can't they felt a little weird
to me it really did what do you think I
mean okay like it personally I think my
very first response when I watched this
was like I don't care but I don't think
I'm the audience for this for this story
I I've never had an abortion but like
you I'm pro-choice I have friends who
have had abortions and I don't think
that I need a YouTube video to
understand the process but that's me I
would research it in different ways I
think if I were faced with that
difficult and let's be honest like she
may have not been going to the Charis
enemy again every demographic exactly
I'm not you know but my second response
when I saw this video was like you know
yeah like it's not well done that's like
I think that that was my problem she's
trying to force with the music and like
oh it's a positive extreme it's like
okay it's it's a personal experience
yeah it's an experience that could have
positive often does have positive
ramifications in somebody's life down
the line but I don't know if having an
outpatient procedure is like you know
something that needs violin music behind
it it just you're right it puts a bad
taste in your mouth a little bit and I
think more than anything all this video
is really going to do is going to
polarize people if you look at where it
was posted the article where I first
read it from was on a conservative site
and the vitriol in the comment section
was like I mean granted she must have
known that was going to happen I don't
blame her I think that you know she has
the right to make this kind of statement
and honestly maybe if she did touch one
or two young women who were like I want
to do this but I'm afraid I think that
it's going to hurt I think it's gonna
you know ruin my life and they watch
that they go maybe it's not that bad I
actually do have an option positive you
know well and you're totally right about
strengthening the other side thing cuz
once this thing got posted on Drudge
then it goes across the right
wing blogosphere and everyone starts
ranting against it do you generally
agree with that I mean I generally do I
think I feel bad because you're right it
did get posted on a conservative website
the comments were so hateful towards her
they said that she got pregnant on
purpose so that she could do this and
get all this attention which is just
because we didn't love having abortion
right I mean I'm not a woman right there
is like really poor easin really touchy
subject and like I almost try to avoid
saying that I'm pro-abortion and say
that I'm pro-choice because no one wants
me pro-abortion like you how abortions
are awesome right but how many people I
think that like it's it's it's something
that most women use as a form of birth
control because it's somehow easier it's
somehow easier to just not think about
it get laid what the [ __ ] ever I'll just
take care of the baby it's like no woman
wants to do that it can't be comfortable
and it is emotional for most people I
have a lot of medical problems sometimes
people can't get pregnant after having
an abortion there's a lot of serious
consequences with it and it can be
psychologically detrimental which is
something that I think the one of the
biggest reasons why I didn't like this
video is because she's just so like
happy the whole time and that's good
because like you said it's important to
show girls we've already made the choice
to have an abortion that it's not going
to hurt you no it's not going to be as
horrible as they might think it could be
and it kind of gives them some
reassurance but at the same time it's
kind of like almost encouraging in a way
right so it sounds like you're both
agreed that her idea was good here but
that the way they produce this with the
music and you know her it like she was
going so far out of her way to make it
seem like it was okay but also you know
we don't see the clinical things it sort
of reminded me of like the death penalty
when we don't see these people being put
to death I'm against the death penalty
anyway but like if we don't see it we
don't know what's going on and by seeing
her laying there it felt much more human
it actually was making me rethink my
position a little bit I'm still
pro-choice I mean that that's kind of
why my first reaction was just like the
production values were so terrible I
feel like if it had been produced a
little bit differently
like if if she had you know edited
things a little bit differently shown it
looked like she selectively edited to
only show the parts where she was the
most comfortable she never once said
like okay this part it's a little income
pastured on past it if it had felt a
little more real to me because I I do
kind of like the idea though that we
were in that room with her
experiencing it with her and she was
sharing that intimate moment so that
people would understand like if I can do
it and you're afraid to do it but you
know you need to do it you can do it too
but it was almost forced in this weird
kind of positive kumbaya bias like he
said yes unreal unrealistic just no
one's going to be that excited and that
happy to go through this process I feel
like it should have showed both sides
right and of course you know she I'm not
saying she got pregnant I'm not going on
to say she got pregnant to do this video
but obviously her allegiances are where
they are because in abortion hauser so
she wanted to spin it in a certain light
what do you guys make of the men
basically that try to tell you what to
do with your bodies because it's pretty
much all men or a huge percentage of men
that that are always voting on abortion
and and even and allegedly writing read
legislation all of that and I'm always
fascinated by it because I literally
cannot understand how someone who does
not have the body parts and can can tell
you what to do with your body parts yeah
I totally agree there needs to be more
women in legislation so that kind of
thing doesn't happen but I don't want to
be too one-sided because I feel like
certain women who are in relationships
have abortions without telling their
significant other and that can be kind
of a gray area I think where you might
need to actually talk to the father I
are you thinking they should have some
sort of like force you know I don't
think iteration I don't think so but I
just feel like to say that you know men
have no say and they shouldn't even be
able to give me their opinion on it I
think that's going all too far I mean of
course I think men should be able to
give you their opinion yeah we're
talking with the people that are voting
yeah I mean but I personally feel very
strongly that until a baby is born like
it's a women's health issue and a
women's health issue alone until in this
you know this organism is viable on its
own what we're really talking about is a
medical condition see as a medical
condition for a woman yeah and it's a
choice that she is deciding to make the
same way that she can make a choice
about the best treatment option for her
cancer the same way that she can make a
choice about you know whether or not she
wants to elect to have certain surgeries
and yes I think that having outside
perspectives is helpful I hope that if
you're you're only lucky enough to be in
a situation where there is a man in your
life always
willing to give you his opinion about
the situation because many times when a
woman is faced with the decision of
having an abortion she's on her [ __ ]
own and that's even more difficult but
it's her choice fundamentally it is her
choice and nobody has a right whether
we're talking about legislators or we're
talking about people with personal
relationships to tell a woman what she
can and can't do with her own pregnancy
because until that baby is born it is a
woman's health
a medical issue so you're saying until
that baby is born do you guys have a
cut-off is there a cut-off point because
that's the other debate you know is it
the the two trimesters is it I think it
seems to me the eight if you were to say
eight months while that baby probably
could live I think it's silly to draw a
line to be honest it's what I think it's
silly to draw a line like obviously when
the baby is born
then there are certain legal issues that
you can't argue with right but before
then I feel like it's an individual's
you know perspective on a situation and
that's why I'm pro-choice because my
opinion on that might not be the same as
somebody else's opinion on that and I
recognize that so I personally don't
think I could go through with having an
abortion but that has nothing to do with
my you know willingness to vote on
whether or not somebody else can you
know I'm not gonna be pushy I mean
obviously there are legal issues that
you know in a perfect world we don't
often think about so sure
maybe there's a woman who's
eight-and-a-half months pregnant she's
abusing drugs and alcohol the courts
want to be able to say right you're
abusing a life inside of you and we
should be able to force you to maybe
stop doing that we should be able to
force you to have the child instead of
global and that's where things start to
get really touchy and really you know
touch-and-go like I said but it's a
complicated topic I think but the
problem most of the time when it comes
to this kind of legislation is not
motivated by those specific situations I
think this legislation is generally
motivated by religious bias and and
there are people who go to the extreme
that they'll say that like the actual
seed the actual sperm is you know
ordained by God and that that shouldn't
even be spilled so I think that I'm
pretty sure my firm oh my god yeah
that's a whole other topic but so final
thought on this is is this you know I
was thinking this putting this type of
thing on YouTube really is such a 2014
thing is there something very freeing
happening in the digital sphere that we
can put this stuff out there and that
whether it's whether it's good or bad
whether we watch this and whether it's
strengthening the other side or not or
whether it's really affect you know
changing anyone's mind that's going to
be more pro-choice
this is all good though just the
information right yeah I think that
overall it's a positive thing just
because it does give that comfort to
girls who've decided to have an abortion
but I do see how it can really be a
lightning rod for the opposite side yeah
and that's what frustrates me the most
because religious people are the ones
who are saying don't masturbate don't
use condoms don't take birth control and
then they want to legislate against
abortions it's like well maybe if you
were a little bit more open-minded about
prevention it's very cool that we're
living in a world right now where free
speech is is kind of helped by
multimedia and by the fact that we can
use something as simple as the the
camera on our phone to produce a video
and to tell a message in a much more
compelling way than just standing
outside and hoping that people will
gather around us to hear what we have to
say and we at least have that freedom on
the internet for a little while longer
although net neutrality was struck down
which we've also talked about a thousand
times so you know good luck to us all
okay let's move on let's talk about porn
because I'm sure that's not going
anywhere around the Internet
Arizona's Republican Governor Jan Brewer
you know Jan Brewer she signed a law
this week cracking down on revenge porn
classifying it as a sex offense of
course revenge porn is when you post
photos or videos usually of an ex of
yours without their consent there's a
bunch of states that have this let's get
a little info on the law
Arizona's strict new law makes revenge
porn a felony establishing an initial 18
months in prison or two-and-a-half years
in prison if the person in the image can
easily be identified it will apply to
any photograph videotape film or digital
recording of a person and it makes it a
crime to disclose display distribute
publish advertise or offer these photos
or video
close this seems all good to me I
usually don't agree with Jan Brewer but
this seems pretty good is there anything
wrong with this kind of law and did we
really just need this because that was
my question like why do we have to say
that you're not allowed to post
revealing photos of your ex on the
internet like that should be obvious
should be I do that I thought of people
sometimes have a bad nature um yeah I
think so yeah I mean it's ridiculous
that this even had to be said like don't
be an [ __ ]
yeah don't write people don't murder
people don't post pictures of people on
the internet for everyone to see and
invade their privacy like that's common
sense wasn't the original 11th
commandment thou shalt not post pictures
blah blah blah yeah all good here all
good Oh completely I mean obviously this
needs to be legislated because people
will argue that this is a violation of
free speech and that they should have
the right to be able to say this and if
there's something in their possession
especially you know it gets complicated
when somebody takes a selfie and the
interesting thing is that some of these
revenge porn laws actually don't apply
to self recorded the in Arizona they do
but in other states some of them don't
apply to like self recorded images which
i think is a nuance that shouldn't be
written into the law but that's where I
think the legality gets confusing
because if I took a picture of myself
naked and gave it to you and said this
is now your property he does that all
the things yeah I don't it's our
relationship yeah that's good don't
judge us okay um we're cool right yeah
yeah so if I did that you should you
know you might be able to argue that
it's now your property and you can do
whatever you want with it
uh no unfortunately there's no waiver
signed there's no release there if there
were a waiver signed this revenge porn
law would not apply right if that's
actually not a terrible idea like have
an app where you're gonna send all your
nudes and you have to actually click
something to say all right no reduction
all the time if I film you on the street
doing an interview and you don't want
your face on camera you can choose not
to sign the release and then you have to
blur your face out so the fact that
these are you know private experiences
that people will ultimately I think I
think that's kind of the interesting
thing about this law it's sort of like
the separation between a typical
violent crime and a hate crime because
it's motivated by something that's
really specific and really dark and kind
of violent and vengeful and because of
that direct motivation I think the
penalty should be stronger because the
actual act is is honestly like what is
your protection of that act like what
can you argue in a courtroom right that
says oh yeah I did not in good faith and
it was you know there's a price in that
picture to all my friends a good thing
yeah I just wanted to promote the
newness of this other day it was great
it's part of the problem here that we
got all this technology so fast you know
what I mean like the Internet is all it
really for for our purposes it's like 20
years old you know I mean it's not that
long ago that it was all dial-up and we
got all of this stuff webcams and phone
cameras and snapchat and we got it all
so fast that everybody started doing all
of this crazy stuff and now it's like we
need these laws to control us because
otherwise it's just endless right yeah
people are people are not the brightest
they'll just do whatever they can with
what they have I mean it's not the
technology's fault though I mean we have
a bunch of things that are disposal it's
your choice to be a jerk with it so no
at the technology's fault but definitely
people are going a little bit crazy and
I have to make laws like this we're
short-sighted as a society that's part
of the problem is that people make
decisions that seem good in the moment
and they don't think about the
ramifications down the line and it's
also difficult because there's no
legislation in place protecting minors
person expression and so yeah we argue
in this country all the time about the
legal drinking age the legal driving age
like at what point are you responsible
enough to operate heavy machinery or
you know take a substance that's
psychotropic and so yeah at what point
are you responsible enough to have a
camera and the ability to upload any
picture that you take onto the Internet
it's difficult when you're a young
person it's even harder to think about
the downstream ramifications and their
biological reasons for that that part of
your brain isn't well developed so and
we're also not socialized to have that
kind of responsibility at that age so
that's where things get difficult that's
why I think it is so important to have
legislation like this yeah I am totally
on board we were all in agreement there
all right there you go let's let's move
on okay
very excited to talk about this because
we do a lot of stuff on this show about
all the crazy [ __ ] that's in our foods
all the whacked-out chemicals that are
in yoga mats that you're eating a pink
slime and everything else and every time
we do one of these stories the comments
section go crazy and they yell at me and
they say I'm anti science because I'm
even bringing this up and it's in there
and it's not going to kill you that
seems to be a general theme I think it's
weird that we beaver anal gland juice is
vanilla flavoring I think that's weird I
know it may not kill me I just think
it's odd that someone was squeezing a
bieber's anus and thought this tastes
good so uh so I wanted to bring onto
people that understand a little more
about science than I do and break some
of this stuff down because you might
have heard this week that coca-cola has
announced that it's not going to use
brominated vegetable oil oil or B vo in
soft drinks such as Fanta fresca and
Powerade anymore and this comes after a
lot of people were talking online about
how bbo is related to compounds that are
found in fire retardants so let's look
at a little more info on BB oh it
contains the chemical bromine which is
also found in fire retardant as I just
said small quantities of bbo are legally
allowed in some drinks to ensure even
flavor distribution according to the
Center for Science in the Public
Interest B vo is a poorly tested and
possibly dangerous food additive and
there's no reason to use it in Gatorade
or other drinks so before we get to the
next thing I want to stop there for a
second because as I said when we do this
everyone yells I mean they say well if
you don't eat a ton of it you'll be okay
we put chemicals in our body all the
time and everything has chemicals and
the ink has getting chemicals in you're
scared bub and you're made of chemicals
and you're made a Michals and all of
that right and all of that so can you
guys give me just sort of a basic break
something can you give me something to
kick this conversation off so I'll start
by saying that I think that the people
in the comment section that there's a
lot of validity to what they're saying
because there is a especially in liberal
media there is kind of a quick tick to
immediately be afraid of anything that
corporation produces and immediately it
be afraid of words like molecules like
chemical and and you know and then all
of a sudden it sounds dangerous we have
this debate all the time with
genetically modified organisms we have
this debate with
you know preservatives food additives or
whatever yeah so there is um there is a
reason to kind of stop sit back and
think about this rationally okay I'm on
board so so we'll start there now I
personally don't know much about BVO as
a food additive but when organizations
that are there to protect the public
interest or do their research and do
their due diligence and say okay we
don't know much about this
there are many nations that have banned
it now that's not reason enough for us
to but here's the clincher for me
there's no reason for it to be there
because you can have the same effect if
you use something that's been proven to
be safe right why aren't we using the
thing that's been proven to be safe I
mean you think it might have something
to do with money yeah you think possibly
it could be a financial decision
probably and this is the cool thing I
think about living in the Internet age
is that if enough people get wind of an
issue and write a petition and get loud
about it and say I'm not gonna buy your
product anymore because I'm afraid of
this one thing that you're using in it
that I don't think has been clearly
tested and I'm not sure about the health
benefits of it we'll just stop buying
coca-cola products coca-cola has to
respond they see a drop in product and
then make their product better even if
it's not killing us they can make it
more natural and that's my probably
basic is it fair to say that things that
are natural are basically good none that
I want to get into the economic argument
yet everything is natural yeah I've ever
known and it occurs in the artificial
stuff yeah it occurs in nature it's
natural I don't I hate to be that
nitpicky but I know that everybody's
gonna say oh please no but I mean it's
true and the thing is it's good to find
things that you think are unhealthy
point them out and replace them with
something that's better especially if
that thing that's better is available I
don't know why like you said we're not
already using that to begin with but any
money but there's a lot of people out
there who like to think about these
things and they freaked out about it
because they want to be like I'm health
conscious I'm going to you know I'm
going to take this initiative and do
better with this issue but they're
ignoring everything else like they're
ignoring the ammonia that people use to
disinfect meat they're ignoring all the
hormones going to I mean yeah I mean
there's just so many things out there
that are exponentially worse but nobody
cares about but they hop onto this one
issue and feel better about themselves
as a whole because they're taking care
of one tiny
little detail okay so just to talk about
the pink line for one second it gets
because it gets everybody nuts and we
got a couple videos on it so basically
they're taking the worst of the worst
meat stuff literally it's falling on the
floor then they pile it all together
they wash it with ammonia you were not
kidding they wash it with ammonia to
kill all the horrible stuff that's on
there and then we eat and it is edible
it is human before they do that process
it's not even fit for human consumption
the meat and then and then it is but
when we've done videos not even then
people say well they've done what
they're supposed to do so it's okay but
you would you would not agree with that
no I wouldn't eat stuff that was washed
with bleach either I mean it doesn't
matter what they've done to it to
disinfect it it's still really unhealthy
not to mention all the hormones and
stuff that you find and meat right it's
just I mean really bad for you I take a
really nuanced approach to like
specifically if we're talking about pink
slime because let's say that I am living
in the inner city and I don't have the
monetary means to eat at Whole Foods
yeah and I don't have them the means to
grow my own food I'm in a whole coarsely
I like the idea of getting back to a
slow food movement I like the idea of
getting back to once you can get to the
source of your food if there's fewer
steps that it takes before that makes it
to your mouth it's more likely I think
generally speaking I'm not going to say
as a rule but generally speaking it's
more likely that that food will be
healthier the less processed it gets the
more process it gets the more we get
into this conversation about food that
weirdly kind of paradoxically makes us
obese but also makes us malnourished and
that's a huge problem in in this country
specifically but also it's going into
other Western nations so when you but
when you say if something is more
natural it's probably better for you
that's [ __ ] because like you can't
eat [ __ ] this is like yeah like you
can't just like go out and eat some
house [ __ ] like that's natural and it'll
make you really sick you can um there
are certain things that we talked about
that first step are horribly dangerous
you know there's toxic things all over
the place in nature and chemic chemical
to extract things and to to add things
together in such a way that they take
natural ingredients and make powerful
drugs out of them and make powerful
substances and may
food use food science to make things
that taste better and that or whatever
and so I think the issue is as you
always like to say and this is an
important point follow the money
like what is the goal here is the goal
feeding people and and feeding them
nutritious food or is the goal you know
a multinational corporations profit
motive coca-cola and I'm the first to
admit I love coke : I drink every day
like my biggest vice it's horrible for
you that's right what you big ass Coca
Cola I drink I drink oh it's a big idea
alright it's like I don't drink alcohol
I don't smoke I don't do drug that smize
like that is my vice but it's not good
for you
like in no sense of the term is drinking
a coke something that you need for like
basic nutrition high fructose corn seed
for you my I feel completely screwing it
causes all sorts of health problems like
liver problems and diabetes like your
body shouldn't take in much sugar yeah
so what we're talking about here is are
these corporations making decisions in
the best interest of your health
probably not
they're probably making decisions in the
best interest of their profits as you
mentioned so we need legislation we need
regulation that protects the consumer
but we also shouldn't be so
trigger-happy that every time we hear
the word chemical it makes us shake in
our boots because everything is made of
chemicals date ok ok so speaking of the
corporation so the the big thing that
kicked this off a couple months ago was
the subway thing that we've alluded to
and the chemical that is in the bread or
was in the bread because they've now
taken out it's called a DA and let's get
some more info about a DA its primary
uses in plastic and rubber products like
yoga mats and flip-flops where it's used
to make them softer and more stretchy so
if you wonder why the bread at Subway is
so fluffy and stretchy you think maybe
at a time doing that many bread products
often contain a DA which is used to make
dough more elastic and a DA is known to
increase the risk of asthma allergies
and skin problems and we've got a list a
bunch of foods that actually contain a
DA McDonald's buns chick-fil-a
sandwiches Burger King buns Dunkin
Donuts Wendy's bread are bees diverse
ecology I mean everything pretty much
everything I don't see in and out on
there which is nice uh so how should we
fear this because this this one seems a
little more close to home to me because
you can sort of like really
Angele see why the breads you know what
I mean you get bread if you get regular
you go to a bakery and get a bread it's
not as fluffy and stretchy so there is
some connection between the rubbery
feeling of a yoga mat and this bread so
can I at least make that well let's see
very separate in our minds like just
because it has one component doesn't
mean we're eating yoga mat like I think
that that is the thing we immediately
jump to is like okay this chemical is
found in these two products so therefore
these two products are the same thing
yeah and so no we are not eating yoga
mats like let's get that clear we can at
least make that jump a little bit more
with this one we don't know if those
quantities in there were harmful I don't
think there's enough research but again
if you can make it without the damn
thing
yeah and it's and there's even a chance
that it's more healthy for the consumer
then there you go that's a great idea I
mean why not and I do like that the
power of the consumers collective voice
made a change for subway because subway
tries to tout themselves as a more
healthy alternative and they don't want
to have things in their food that are
going to make health-conscious consumers
turn away but if you're really that
concerned about it the first option
would be don't eat fast food just don't
eat is that at the end of the day final
thoughts I mean is that really the end
that like you can at least get that out
that's what I've been thinking this
whole time like I don't want to say you
shouldn't fix a problem that exists
because if you can use something
healthier then use it but at the same
time you're freaking out over one
chemical whenever you're eating
McDonald's hamburger think about what
you're eating how gross it is and all
the crap that's in there and you're
freaking out about a DA like it just
seems a little bit and also I know the
people will make the economic argument
that you talk about for and they'll say
they're not they don't have access to
this other food and things of that
nature but I do think that you know you
can buy a can of tuna for a dollar fifty
and yes I'll probably die of mercury
poisoning as my mom reminds but like
there are some cheaper ways to eat
things and I know it's not as quick as
McDonald's but there are ways so it's
not totally tied up the deck is stacked
against you my advice is never throw up
your hands and just give up right yes
this deck is stacked against you and
unfortunately you're going to see people
in certain economic situations having
less options and it's going to be harder
to make healthy decisions and so yes
that [ __ ] sucks and it's unfair and I
think we should be pushing to have more
healthy
grocery options in lower-income
neighborhoods I'm not saying that it the
option or the best option is just
[ __ ] eat McDonald's and cry about it
like obviously fast-food is not healthy
like Point Blank it's just not healthy
to eat fast food and as you said why are
we
nitpicking about this one thing when
there's a million other reasons that
fast food is not healthy yes
opt for healthier options but let's all
keep in mind as we're sitting here in
our comfy chairs in West Hollywood that
some people don't have the options that
we have so we should at least maintain
perspective about that technically we're
in Culver City which we are quite as
nice as well more people would know that
I tried to use something that they could
reference all right well I think we got
a good segue here from foods you should
meet this is an interesting study that
came out Experian marketing services
conducted a rolling survey to determine
whether there any patterns between
politics and food and a rolling survey
is where you gather information over a
long period of time and there are some
interesting findings which we've got a
bunch of the first one is conservative
versus liberal food chain so this is
where conservatives like to eat
conservatives love Oh Charlies Cracker
Barrel that one doesn't surprise me they
like Hometown Buffet
what is that next one Papa Papa Papa
Murphy's Longhorns steakhouse okay so
these seem these are meaty kind of
things hearty hearty knows where the
liberals eating California Pizza Kitchen
that socialist you know macaroni grill
Ruth's Chris Steakhouse that one's kind
of pricey on the border that's Mexican
PF Changs everybody likes a little you
know chained Asian food
next up conservative versus liberal fast
food chains so the Conservatives they're
digging crystal I actually don't know
what that is
so burger I don't know crystal burger
that's kinda funny little burgers yeah
it's kind of like White Castle is kind
of the exact same thing same thing as
well okay they like crystal what else is
on there what a burger that's mostly
down south I've seen in Texas uh
Schlotzsky's Deli which also I don't
know that one where
my New York anomaly Sharma chick-fil-a
that one doesn't surprise me and they
like Steak and Shake which is big in the
Midwest where the Liberals in their
fast-food a bond pun oh yes there no
there's snooty friends are all hanging
out in airports apparently a lot of red
water bread Chipotle and you know
because / Tripoli is supposed to be you
know relatively healthy for you as far
as that goes
kotoba which is basically a chipotle
knock off blue pee
I thought that was interesting they like
it more than subway or what's the
Quiznos and Starbucks we of course know
that the Liberals are always hanging out
in Starbucks at one [ __ ] supermarket
chains chains this is where the
Conservatives are going they're going to
Randall's Weis markets Piggly Wiggly
Brookshire's and food town interestingly
that's so liberal Brookshire's
looks-wise Brookshire's Brookshire hey
can we go back and say can we go back
that one for just a sec so I these first
well Piggly Wiggly I know but I don't
think I've been to any of these first
four food towns big on the East Coast
yeah these are the rest of these all do
you guys know where these these are all
seven Midwestern southern I've only ever
done Piggly Wiggly you've done here
where the Liberals doing their food
shopping
uh well enough these liberals go to
Whole Foods whole paycheck foods is they
going Trader Joe's that's where I do
most of my shopping Fred Meyer Acme and
Safeway so there are some interesting I
think we can glean some interesting
stuff out of this do you think you can
get more information about what people
believe politically by this kind of
stuff than by polling them on actual
politics I think there might be
something to that liberals obviously are
much healthier is that going back to the
previous segment yeah
liberals sorta want healthier stuff yeah
more vegetarians yeah yeah I do I mean I
think that if you were some sort of
advertising your consumer marketing
company and you wanted to be sneaky
about the way that you reach your
consumer yes you could go this route but
I don't think you're gonna glean more
information about somebody's political
views than asking them point blank what
are your political views I don't think
that there's some ulterior like weird
now everybody who Shops at Whole Foods
exactly everybody
truth is I think that this is a [ __ ]
study like point-blank this is a
[ __ ] study I remember once doing
maybe it was the Young Turks maybe it
was the point I remember I had a role of
being on the show with us and talking
about maybe it was even the common room
and talking about a similar study that
was like I can tell your political
persuasion based on the alcohol that you
drink and it's like know what you can
tell is where I live in the country and
the truth is there's a high correlation
between this type of food consumption
and regional differences and there's
also a high correlation between those
regional differences and political
affiliation and now those things are
being conflated carrot this is a hundred
percent why I bring well because I'm not
always sold on these studies but I think
that very interesting that they get out
there so if someone can debunk them a
little bit I'm not sure there's also a
high correlation between people that
wear Wranglers and people that wear I
don't know J Brand Jeans and their
political persuasion it's because of
where you live
J Brand that's gonna be California
that's right L born in New York it's
gonna be a higher scale client who Shops
at you know Nordstrom or sex with Avenue
and Wrangler jeans like I'm from Texas I
know this this is gonna be something
that people in the South are gonna be
more likely to wear it's a more of a
fashion statement that you see in the
south right and so it's gonna be more
likely that those people are
conservative and they're probably gonna
drink say whiskey instead of wine do you
think that that's possible
yeah or whiskey instead of vodka for
example so I think these are really just
regional differences in people because
that's where I think some of these some
of these restaurants so take advantage
of those regional differences and are
there on purpose because I know in the
South they're cracker barrels everywhere
really and I have friends who refuse to
go to them because when you walk in it's
like there's Jesus music playing there's
hats it's a John 3:16 on them all these
Bibles out and they just feel
uncomfortable so they won't go into
Cracker Barrell gravy biscuits they make
a hell of a potato it's really hard to
link to with this conversation that we
have a lot of times about voting with
your dollar
which I think starts to you know the big
chick-fil-a debate which I mean maybe
I'm just a sucker and I grew up in Texas
and I really like chick-fil-a I
apologize I'm not homophobic you know
they say no but I like homophobic
chicken because it tastes really good
and here's here's part of the issue I
think is that it's the deck is
stacked against a lot of consumers in
this country and if we chase the money
ultimately we're going to get to
something we don't like ultimately we're
going to get to something that we are
polarized about and that we're
politically against and I get it if
you're somebody who can take the time to
do your due diligence and do all of your
research and figure out where you want
to shop based on your political
affiliations that's great and more power
to you but I don't like it when people
get high and mighty about telling other
people that they should do that to you
because like there's not enough [ __ ]
time in the day to research every single
thing I spend my money on yeah it gets
confusing I mean you know left to right
like Dolce & Gabbana are going to prison
right now for tax evasion in Italy and
like if you're against that you know
it's it goes from the top to the to the
bottom it goes from high to low if
you're in a dark room all the time
hello and pretty much never shop
anywhere if you don't get gas at BP
exactly and somebody's making it's like
is it any better to get gas at Exxon no
and somebody's making a decision if
you're shopping at a multinational
conglomerate probably that they're
making money on the backs of other
people and this is a big difficulty in
capitalist society yes you can I
generally opt to eat at in and out over
these other choices because a it's
healthier right and B I do appreciate
their corporate values a little bit more
and I'd much rather go to a mom-and-pop
then go to a big chain but there are
times when I'm stuck I still have to put
gas in my car
the old lady we live in we all make
different choices and interesting the BP
thing you know the oil spill obviously
whichever which they were completely at
fault for most people were boycotting
their gas stations which are franchised
so you weren't even hurting the the
corporation the conglomerate you were
hurting the individual franchisees which
had nothing to do with any of the safety
thing at chick-fil-a is it's a jelly
franchise and so you see like the
chick-fil-a here in West Hollywood is
not a homophobic chick-fil-a at all
people are boycotting and they're like
we're [ __ ] with all they would like
look at everybody who works here like we
don't care and that's a problem you know
it's that we don't know all of the ins
and outs a lot of these deals are done
kind of in the dark and they're shadowy
and the the records aren't available to
the consumer and taking political action
via your food choices I think is a good
idea but I also don't think it's always
a
reasonable idea alright people there you
go we don't know everything about what's
in our food and who's selling us our
food we're doing the best we can okay
I wanted to talk about this I thought it
was interesting esatto Saudi Arabia's
King Abdullah Saudi Arabia one of our
biggest allies in the Gulf which doesn't
let women vote or drive but that's a
different topic altogether has
introduced a series of new laws which
defines atheists as terrorists this is
according to a report from the Human
Rights Watch and this the laws basically
have come into play because of the
growing number of Saudis that are
travelling to into Syria to fight in the
civil war there and then they're
returning to Syria with newfound
thoughts on freedom and they now have
all these new military skills and the
monarchy is basically afraid that all of
these new ideas is going to cause what's
happening in Syria to happen in Saudi
Arabia let's look at royal decree 44 it
criminalizes participating in
hostilities outside the kingdom with
prison sentences of between 3 and 20
years article one of the new provisions
defined terrorism as calling for atheist
thought in any form or calling into
question the fundamentals of the Islamic
religion on which this country is based
I thought as a Star Wars guy I thought
it was funny the coin Royal Decree 44
which sounds so much like order 66 which
is where they killed all the Jedi but I
don't have to tell you do that okay
we've got two two atheist here right I
mean I know you well enough and I know
you're what well I'm gonna flip this
card with I don't believe that there's
somebody up there judging me but I
believe in a force basically but I don't
think I believe that they something huh
I believe there's something happening
here that I can't really explain but I
don't believe deal even God I don't
think God cares how much I jerk off or
you know that kind of thing he's not
like yeah I get God whatever you wanna
call God probably created this little
universe and now is creating some others
fun no not watching even as a jest
yeah that's a deist I think you'd be
like in trouble with right Saudis oh I'm
sure that would not be thrilled but I
don't think they'll make it okay sure
okay um so all right so as a theist is
there is this the most bonkers thing
you've ever I love that I can be a
terrorist without doing anything
I know literally atheism is less than
Christian like it it's doing less than
being religious it is a lack of belief
so literally without doing anything
making any decisions having any belief
system or insights into anything we're
terrorists but can you understand why a
monarchy that has so much control of
their people and as I said doesn't let
women vote or drive yet can you
understand why that in a weird way is
more of a threat I can sort of see why
they'd see that concept as more of a
threat than actually terrorism if you AR
see that's a problem with living under a
theocracy is that you're going to have
legislation in place that's morally
directed that's fundamentally based on
your specific religious values and it's
going to by its very nature target
individuals that don't fit into that box
and you know look at what's happening
right now in Brunei where the Sultan of
Brunei is passed Sharia law in this
country I mean it's [ __ ] insane like
you're I'd much rather go chop up
someone's hand now for all feelings if I
go to Brunei like I will be put to death
in five minutes like I will figure out
how to break some sort of law that will
you know they'd kill you they'd execute
exactly and so I'd rather go to Saudi
Arabia but these are shades of [ __ ] is
what we're talking about right now and
yeah the way are you boycotting the
beverly hotel because they're bad yeah
beverly hills hotel because that's owned
by the sultan of brunei you happy i
generally spend a lot of money at the
beverly an easy boycott for me um but
yeah i mean i think these are all shades
of the same thing you know if we talk
about oppression of women and we talk
about oppression of atheistic values
what we're really talking about is a
theocracy trying to maintain
to religious values which are patriarchy
and kind of core you know power in the
hands of the rich in the hands of the
people who who can use these kind of
religious codes to control the decisions
that the lesser lands in the I mean it's
a [ __ ] age-old story it's depressing
a [ __ ] that we're living in 2014 and
we're seeing this but it doesn't
surprise me that Saudi Arabia makes
these decisions what pisses me off is
that they're a strong ally of America
same as Brunei by the way we're an ally
of a country with Sharia law and that's
all because they have oil so I that's
that's the next thing I wanted to bring
up and with without getting into major
geopolitical discussion do we have to
reevaluate some of our alliances on some
of these places that have such horrific
human rights where they're literally
stoning gay people to death and for the
third time now women can't vote and
drive I mean it's such fundamental basic
simple human right do we have to
reevaluate who were friends with even
though yeah they've got a lot of oil and
apparently we like well yeah I I was
actually just going to pose that
question to you guys because it's like a
really touchy subject but I find it hard
to imagine that I'm in a country that's
supporting that type of environment for
people I feel so bad I get messages from
people all the time from the Middle East
and they're scared to even write me the
message because if somebody were to see
it they could be executed yeah so for
people that have to live in that or
people who are being killed because
they're gay like I just I just don't
understand why we would you know use
money as enough of an incentive to
support that type of environment and
that's the problem we're so entrenched
in this kind of American exceptionalism
and this political like whatever my
country thinks I think too that we
actually use phrases like why do we
support I [ __ ] support then but my
government does and that's unfortunate
for a lot of people because it makes us
look on the world stage like we are
willing to turn the other way we're
willing to turn the turn the other way
about these humans rights violations
which we are which we exactly and that's
the real problem I'm not right but as a
nation we are and that's basically
because of what you said it's that
dependence on oil and I think that if we
got to a place where we were less
dependent on fossil fuels and
I'm not even about foreign fossil fuels
but fossil fuels in general and we
really embraced a more green movement
which is helpful for a million reasons
it's helpful to the economy it's helpful
to the environment I mean there's only
positive side effects of making these
decisions we this won't even this
wouldn't be a conversation
Obama would immediately be like [ __ ] you
guys we're not going to give you eight
anymore not until you you know lift this
ban or not until you stop you know
killing people for their beliefs well so
even Obama's not above politics I can't
believe I just gave a final bonus cuz
we're talking about atheism uh what what
do you guys personally say to the people
that say there are no atheists in
foxholes so the people that say on your
deathbed
you're gonna retract everything you
believe in a bunch of [ __ ]
take it away horrible that's horrible I
know that Christopher Hitchens spoke a
lot about this whenever he was dying
yeah he definitely didn't take back
anything that he said and I think that
that's really an insult to your
intelligence saying you obviously can't
hold your beliefs true because if you
were in the situation you throw it all
away so you're almost in a phase until
you need God or religion or something
and that's just insulting to your
character and your intelligence yeah
it's also putting such a strange onus on
the atheist I always think like their
can believe everything they believe in
for their entire life except for the
last switch it's just it's just one more
way for them to say we're right and
you're wrong because one day you're
gonna agree with me and truth is if we
were raised in a nation where religion
was never taught where there was no
cultural bias toward religion and then
we went to war for our country and then
we found ourselves in a foxhole we
wouldn't make up the concept of God like
we're atheists by default
religion is indoctrinated into us so of
course some people go back to their
earlier mentalities because they were
raised that way but I don't know any
atheist who in the late stages of life
who were never exposed to religion who
are all of a sudden like I'm going to
invent some sort of religion as a as a
means of feeling safe and and
comfortable just gonna bring that up
I've met a lot of people who are raising
their kids without religion and I've had
a conversation with a kid they're like I
just don't understand how people think
these crazy things you know I don't
believe in Santa Claus anymore and I
just think it's really important that
people could
step back and imagine that they never
had that a doctor nation imagine that
they never were brought up with religion
and then tell yourself the religion
story again whether you're Muslim or
Christian or whatever you are it would
sound ridiculous so I want to ask those
people who ask me what I would do at my
deathbed well why on your deathbed
aren't you going to start praying to
Allah yeah you know she could be wrong
might as well cover all the bases yeah
and that's that's you know a common
thing that they that they say kind of an
atheist circles which is that we're all
a theist I just go one God deeper yeah
there you go
well I hope we gave you a smart and
heady show as I promised up top I want
to thank Jaclyn Glenn Cara Santa Maria
their Twitter's are right down below
don't forget to subscribe comment all
that stuff that we indoctrinate you to
do on the YouTube because that is truly
the supreme power okay we'll see you
next week